- [Voiceover] This episode
of CC: Social Scene
is based on your suggestions
for what can go wrong
on a hike without GPS.
- Oh you guys, what a
beautiful day for a hike.
- Yeah if Dave
doesn't ruin it first.
- Yeah Dave.
- Oh my tummy, I'm so sick.
- My appendix burst.
- Oh god I'm gonna die!
(laughter)
- So according to the GPS the
hike is one hour that way.
- Okay that is enough of that.
Guys, today we are roughing it.
- We're not even
on the trail yet.
- Well hiking starts the
second you step out of the,
out of the car.
(sighs)
Guys, it's summer.
Right, this is our one chance
to connect with nature.
Did Christopher
Columbus have a GPS?
No!
He discovered America.
I got it, I got it.
America.
How 'bout we vote?
All of those who
want to live free
and really connect with
this beautiful Mother Gaea.
- Yeah.
- Raise those hands.
- Oh that's a good one.
- Raise them high!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
- Mother Gaea?
- Look it up buddy,
it's on the internet.
Well don't 'cause
I took your phone.
(upbeat guitar music)
(bird screeches)
- We're lost.
- Yeah we've walked past
that tree four times
and I'm out of water.
- I haven't taken a selfie
in like three hours.
- Sorry guys, we're
not lost, alright?
- If you look, there's the sun.
So that means our car is
right over, no, okay hold on.
The sun is, it's hard
to, we're not lost.
- Brody can we please
have our phones back?
- You mean these?
- Yes.
- What?!
(screaming)
- We don't need that stuff guys.
Alright, was that drastic?
- Yes!
- Yes.
Was that necessary?
- No!
- Maybe, maybe because
we don't need GPS.
We can do this!
We are young, and we are strong!
Right, say it!
- We are young
and we are strong!
- No no no, enough enough.
Alright, let's go.
Come on.
(screaming)
Okay, don't touch
him, don't touch him.
- Why not?
- I am so hungry.
Do you have anything
in that bag I can eat?
- You want some beef jerky?
- I can't eat that,
I'm a vegetarian.
You got anything else?
- Nope.
- Crap, I'm gonna
die in the woods.
- You're gonna be fine.
We got plenty of sun
and plenty of time.
(bird cooing)
- Well, we're lost.
And it's all thanks to Captain
Throws Phones Over There.
- Calm down Dave, you don't
wanna burst your other appendix.
- You only have one!
- Okay.
- One appendix!
- Everybody relax.
I know where we are.
- Really Brody, where are we?
- We are in the woods.
- Thanks for--
(screaming)
- Stop guys, look at us!
If anybody should
be mad here it's me!
I'm the guy who hurt his, ow!
(screams)
Oh that was the other one.
Great, okay, just
because we're lost
doesn't mean we have
to all go crazy.
(growling)
- I did my way, I did my way.
(screaming)
- I have returned!
And I bring food!
- Give me the snail!
- I want the snail!
- Earn it.
(shrieking)
(screaming and animal sounds)
(snoring)
(grunts)
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Join
the conversation now
with CC: Social Scene.
Make up some new
ultimate frisbee lingo
and we might write it
into our next sketch.
Presented by Redd's Apple Ale.
Crisp like an apple,
brewed like a beer.